después de un acuerdo firmado con la
intermediación de las naciones unidas y
turquía estos barcos están listos para
salir sin embargo el futuro de este
acuerdo todavía tiene bastantes
interrogantes por delante
en el acuerdo está escrito que no se
pueden atacar navíos o puertos que están
involucrados en esta misión como se les
dio primero por las instalaciones del
puerto se lee que es toda la
infraestructura del puerto rusia lo lee
como esas partes donde están los barcos
con los grandes pero si yo soy el dueño
de un barco y algo a 500 metros de su
barco es destruido obviamente usted no
entiende que hay condiciones de
seguridad apropiadas para el barco y la
tripulación están en desarrollo creen
poder ser pero hay un obstáculo más son
las minas lanzadas al mar durante estos
meses de guerra ya se fue de smart solo
por los barcos lo que planean es crear
una caravana de barcos el barco cabecero
es el que se encarga del desminado
haciendo una revisión y en el caso de
que vea algo tal como se hizo en el
golfo pérsico en la guerra de irán e
irak
se detienen los miran y los barcos
continúan pero esto significa mucho se
puede imaginar todas las complicaciones
complications camiones como estos se ven
alrededor de ucrania actualmente
recogiendo esas cosechas y muchos de
ellos vienen hacia el mar negro donde
nos encontramos aquí lo almacenan en
galpones pero los exportadores dicen que
no tienen el suficiente lugar donde
guardarlo y eso termina por influir en
la calidad del producto y también en su
precio final
porque las instalaciones ucranianas
nunca han estado listas para guardar el
grano por largo tiempo nunca existió la
necesidad de hacerlo lobe pero ahora nos
enfrentamos a ellos como un tema gigante
lo que significa que el precio de caerá
significativamente en esas cosechas y
esto afectará a los campesinos y ahora
ellos sacrificarán el margen de ganancia
ahora con el objetivo de poder llegar a
la siguiente cosecha next cube en este
acuerdo está rodeado de grandes
interrogantes lo que es cierto es que de
hacerse realidad aliviará la vida de
millones de personas en ucrania como en
el resto del mundo